Suns like the very attractive noise
that's easy to dog not very attractive
voice it's me sir attractive boys let's
meet the let's be the gentlemen behind
the very attractive boy
[Applause]
please welcome to go god benedict
cumberbatch everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you exist you will never get to see this
w I've never seen this before man first
[Music]
many many of me are happy to basically
and he he heads up his team of the north
wind which looks off our welfare
wherever it needs looking after
and he knows about this plot he's after
Octavius brine and sir constipating wins
to try and get as much information as
possible
it's like extorting rendition I think
it's a little bit more merciful than
that and he kind of brings him into
north wind and tries to to get
information so that he can take his team
to do the professional body in the
acting as well you enjoy the you'll join
the enemies
enjoy the experience I like use my body
yeah no I do I mean it's uh it's very
weird on that level because you are
you're in isolation the first time I met
John was yesterday and I got to us here
this legend of acting this extraordinary
brilliant man in the first question I
got John Surma sunlight so what was it
like playing an evil octopus my name is
William I just wanna say thank you John
[Music]
absolutely to ask you directly so that's
why I'm here okay we just want to know
for Penguins of Madagascar another
voiceover roles what's the process that
you go through to convey so much emotion
into the movie from the cold Sabu
you have to go and they cover for a long
time
worked in Yellowstone Park as a wolf for
a while I was accepted into the back
quite quickly got a bit hairy when no
pun intended when I became the alpha
male that's half of it about three weeks
from now about a month into it I
realized that two of the other ones were
Christian that I think is getting on
wolf actually you know going to the
bathroom which that's a new education
and eating habits a little bit awkward
and don't put any Katniss in front of me
that is great fun I mean in all
seriously you know you do you throw
yourself around a little bit it's not
like motion-capture it's not like this a
full body experience that that is but
yeah you there are only certain things
you can actually make a voice to do
without voting so at times I was
imagining things hitting me was holding
onto a playing and yeah that's that just
takes you a thing about being a bit of a
body and having Ariminum issues
whatsoever which I did have but I did I
enjoyed it I joined it it's grateful
thank you okay just now surprising
[Music]
it was in my imaginary space wasn't it I
turned out alright and I wasn't one of
them and spawn my interests in the
written word like that power to create
those imaginary worlds beyond that to
the vision wise I think all sorts of
things I mean I was a clear the area so
the 18 werewolf an animal all those
Nightrider
and then gentlemen - because I shared
the name eager just at the image it was
probably two stories about it probably
stories adult stories I shouldn't be
shouldn't have been hearing at the age I
had that but also you know they were
very good at creating worlds and
characters right yeah imagine firstly I
want to say hi Craig my dad and I watch
your show every night so they love you
and then okay I'm gonna try not to cry
[Music]
and my question was you know you said
you're new to voice acting and I was
wondering what new techniques he needed
to bring to the table versus like stage
or screen acting I'm in a bit of radio
so that's probably the most helpful
medium to cabin pressure reads and
that's very policy the hardest thing the
most useful thing is to do an adaptation
of a book because you are the book
you're the narrative voice if you also
all the individual characterizations so
that you really do get that ego driven
playing all the plants and with that you
have to imagine a lot of the scenarios
and this is a great team of writers and
directors and artists who can lead you
through step by step to give you a very
firm idea of how to contextualise
you still have to take a little leave
yourself together but when it's not like
that that's the hardest thing I say I
have ever done vocally so with their
help their scripts and their genius it's
kind of a walk in the park and you just
get to end up improvisation is very
important something they need to be free
with an idea push an idea go too far
come back do the full circle thing you
do rehearsals you know good idea the
beginning call for ideas for a restavek
coming back to the same good idea all
right I do
that at the end of that process is
really not not to be kind of
experimenting I was really I was really
looking forward to working with the
Penguins and Jonathan and my team I've
not met a single one of my team so
that's it's really bizarre and that's
almost the hardest thing you don't have
the usual camaraderie which you do in
most other mediums but I did my champion
I didn't really fall for smokey because
I was I was anyone I was doing motion
captures Martin was in England and would
be the size of a fleck of dust on the
carpet in the army that would be pretty
difficult to imagine him as that and
it's I'm a great actor reading off lines
like I did every single session with
recording this yeah you don't build that
chemistry there right now nice in
improvising against Korean writers in
the studio software this watching it but
these are my two first audience all of
our first ones if you make that not
right you know you're somewhere in the
right ballpark and they just keep on
going
do you ever feel because
they really want you to see their warts
but you really want to see other words
[Music]
you know hi I'm Heidi I'm also from
Florida and I with the repatched podcast
and we have a question mostly for
Benedict basically some sort of estimate
or you sort of answered it before but
what's the different process for you in
working on something animated like this
versus a radio show where you not only
have your code or coworkers with you but
also an audience that's allowed to ask
about Sherlock so I'll just say what's
your experience will you come back to
Sherlock next year yeah
[Music]
I see if I come back here I think make
up a good show hi there my question is
for John and for Benedict mm-hmm you've
both played villains if you had your
choice what classic kind of book hero
would you like to play we didn't ask for
suggestions from that flower Lois Lane
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wait for it
penny drop again that's all we have time
for from floor so before we conclude I
have a special treat for you apparently
first of all please thank the cast and
filmmakers
[Music]
Benedict Cumberbatch code Malkovich